بايران مشاهدينا وحشيه النظام واساليب
القمع ما بتنتهي ومن وقت ما انخفض الشعب
الايراني وقرر انه ينزل على الشارع ويعبر
عن رفضه لممارسات النظام صارت السلطات
الايرانيه تستخدم كل الوسائل حتى الاعدام
كمان لاخفاء اصوات المطالبه او اصوات
مطالبه باسقاطها وبعد تنفيذ عدد من احكام
الاعدام غردت الممثله والمنشطه الايرانيه
اثنين بانيادي على تويتر وعبرت عن قلقها
من احتمال اعدام ارميت عباسي وهي احدى
معتقلات الاحتجاجات الميته عباسي من
مواليد عام 2001 وكانت قوات الامن
الايراني اعتقالتها بشهر اكتوبر في مدينه
كرش وبحسب موقع هانا الحقوقي يقال انه
اعتقال العباسي صار بعد ناشرها ببعض
المواد في الفضاء الالكتروني
على كل حال عن هاي القصه وعن استمرار
الاحتجاجات في ايران تنضم الينا من
بروكسيل الباحث في الشان الايراني
مناسلاوي اهلا فيك يا ست منى معانا ست منى
يعني واضح بانه بالفعل اساليب ال النظام
الايراني عم تزداد
قسوه وبشاعه يوم بعد يوم وعم نلاقي انه
احكام الاعدام عملها بتصدر بحق حتى يعني
صغار السن بشكل غير انساني ابدا عم نشوف
عم نحكي عن صبيه ممكن انها همم يعني ينفذ
بحقق همم حكم الاعدام وهي عمرها بس 21 سنه
كيف نقدر نفهمه هل هناك اي طريقه لوقف هاي
الممارسات الايرانيه البشيعه
تحياتي لك وللمشاهدين يعني اول احب اعلق
على ارميتا عباسي اول مره سمعنا اسمها هي
كان قبل شهر عندما اخذت الى مستشفى امام
علي من بواسطه قوات الامنيه انا ما يبدو
هي كان لديها نزيف داخلي وكان لديها تشقق
في مناطق يعني تبين انه كان عليها اثار
الاغتصاب الجنسي اللي تعرضت لها في في
السجون همم الرئيس المستشفى
موجوده في المستشفى قاموا بسرقه ارميته من
الباب الخلفي من المستشفى ورجعها على
السجن وهي في حالتها الكارتيه ارميتها
كانت بلوجر وكان لديها يعني صفحه على
اليوتيوب وانستغرام كانت تنشر الحياه يعني
هي كانت بالفعل تمثل الشعب الحيويه شو
المعلومات اللي نشرتها على الفضاء
الالكتروني اللي ممكن تودي فيها لا حكم
الاعدام بالفعل خصوصا اذا انت بتقولي انه
هي كانت اصلا ناشطه يعني بتنشر اشياء عن
حياتها مش اكثر
جمهوريه الانسانيه جمهوريه الاسلاميه
تتحكم في حياه المواطن يعني بمجرد هي تنشر
محتوى وهي غير محجبه تنشر محتوى وهي قد
تتكلم عن حقوق الانسان او حقوق المراه او
اساسا تعيش حياه خاصه تتكلم انه لدي
اصدقاء واحضرنا حفلات هذه تعتبر جريمه
ولكن هي بهذه الاحتجاجات كي هي بنت اخرى
همم يعني تعبت من الحياه تحت الضغط
نسميها بسببها باستمرارها اكثر من 100 يوم
هي تعتبر لها يعني تعتبر جريماتها اللي
اذيتها لها اغتصابها تعذيبها لمده ثمانيه
ايام بعد الاجابه على مستشفى سرقتها مره
ثانيه للمستشفى والان يعني هناك خطوره بعد
شهرين لان احنا النهار ما نعرف ما هي
ظروفها اللي احتماليه اعدامها ولكن اود ان
لانه اعدام القاصرات القاصرات انا اتكلم
ليست اول مره ببدايه الثوره بايام خميني
كان يتم اعدام القاصرات البكر يعني
اعمارهم تحت 18 سنه رايت له منتظري اللي
يذكر اسم بنت تاريخ بانه وقف وجه خميني
ولم يقبل جرائم خميني قال لهم لا يجوز قتل
ال- ال- البنت القاصره البكر اعدامها فرد
كان من قبل القوات الحرس الثوري سوف نقوم
بالتزويجهن فكان بهالدرجه من الوحشيه وغير
انسانيه اللي كانوا مثلا في يوم عزاء
البنت اللي كانت معدومه كان احد القوات
الحرس الثوري كان يروح ويذهب ويقدم لهم
الحلو والولد ويقول انا زوجه بنتكم قبل
الاعدام يعني هذه التصرفات موجوده وموثقه
انا لا اقول قصص وحكايات يعني اهالي
البنات المعلومات ولكن مع الاسف يعني
اللغه الفارسيه نوع من التغطيه للجمهوريه
الاسلاميه لان احنا ايه حدث في اي دوله
عربيه في 300 مليون مواطن يتكلمون فيها
ايران
معلش اسمحي لي ست منى يعني في زمن
السوشيال في ميديا ماضل في شيء بيخبط يعني
كل ما يحصل في اي بلد سيخرج للعلن وكل
الناس راح تعرفه وربما من ابرز الاشياء
اللافته في هذه الاحتجاجات او الانتفاضه
الايرانيه هي انه رغم هذه القعده رغم
الوحشيه الكبيره اللي بيتعمل معها بيتعمل
فيها النظام مع شعبه الا لانه هذا لم يثني
هذا الشعب وما زال حتى لم يثني او يخيف
صغار السن من قاصرين او حتى اكبر شويه من
انه يعبروا عن رايهم انسان عنده هذه
الاحتجاجات
يعني هذا السوشيال ميديا لان احنا نسمع عن
هذه الجرائم ولكن شعب الايراني عاش 40 سنه
لذلك ليست جديد عليه لذلك لا يتراجع لا
يخاف اسقط الخوف لانه صار له 40 سنه يعيش
هذه الامور قضيه الاغتصاب بالسجون ليست
اول مره يعني دائما مع الاسف بكل احتجاج
يحصل ولذلك اشخاص اللي رايحين على الشارع
يعرفون ما يحصل لهم وتعبوا من استمرار
الحياه وهكذا
تراجعوا سيكون هناك انتفاضه اخرى فيكون
اقتصاد مره اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك منى
السيلاوي الباحثه في الشان الايراني كانت
معنا من بروكسل شكرا
[موسيقى]